es ist einfach hell und nein es ist aber
so knapp ist einfach du denkst du bist
schon unten und dann ist anders und
scheiße eisblock hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu wie drop hat zwei
zusammen mit dem kran der komischerweise
14 fans mehr hat als ich auch so
wertvollen die ganze kiste ist ab und
ratet mal wer am letzten part auf seinem
kanal ausgeglichen hat ja ja wir beide
zwei diamanten marc vogel
wir erwerben werden wie viele diamanten
gefunden weißt du das auch den habe ich
auch gefunden aber ich habe vier
gefunden glaube ich und du gar keine
burger kann ich hab gar an der und
müssen wir an zwei geschenkt so war das
war heute sind wir jetzt bei level
number sowie tree maker scheiße alter
richter schon höre ich habe mir fallen
durch irgendein baum durch luca mit
fallen liegt man hier bei der map nie
nie verheiratet was golden ist das
könnte eventuell liegt nicht falsch ich
dachte gerade geschafft lisa schummler
aber da ist ja ich weiß nicht was
irgendwann bei seinem fleiß schon mal wo
man lang fallen muss ich kann ich nicht
schlagen doch dann gehen kannst überall
irgendwie anfangen
ja aber da war wasser was ich halt eben
gesehen habe ach ja ich glaube und
müssen wir alles voll wasser das im atx
an
durch stetiges wasser von klima herrscht
natürlich dann gut
das war knapp
bei mir hat er ja da war wasser aber es
ist nicht über als ist und so kleinen
teich
es sind kleine teiche schlecht wurde
schlechter hätte nicht sterben können
komm schon kommt schon kommt schon
wir müssen wir müssen einfach erst
standardmäßig in jedem fall so mutig
typen reinpacken oder so einfach weiß
was gut ist dann fällt mir auch niemals
einen tempel
komm schon ins wasser ich sage ich
strenge mich an und ich voll auf den
ersten verfügten us den ist an diesem
scheiß baum gibt
bischkek rpo jung ist es ärgerlich und
jetzt ist meine tonspur noch irgendwie
weiß ich nicht ich muss das ganze ein
bisschen kommt schon kommt schon komm
schon ich bin war erst im wasser wäre es
im wasser scheiße alter jetzt lasst es
so jetzt müssen die kids zu suchen
jetzt müssen wir wahrscheinlich diesen
schwarzen knopf wiederfinden den den ich
gefunden habe
hier macht kunden habe ich nicht weiß wo
bist du das müssen wir irgendwo wieder
halten schnauzte
technisch hoch springen ich hab's
gefunden ich habe es gefunden
komm schon kommt ich hoffe ich lebe ich
bin auch ein ast gefallen und ich lebe
irgendwie noch weil man immer noch so
ein bisschen länger leben dingsbums ok
cool cool cool cool cool logistics hey
ich bin in der ich bin auch hier
hier ist nichts als ich dachte dass
irgendwas ist dass das goldene ei seite
aber dass da irgendwas man scheiße das
schild das ein schild wie kommt man denn
da hoch der bonus comcom
was bitte ist die idee kommt und
geschaffter schafft es
junge oder schlecht
ich hab' ich habe eine idee aber wenn
ihr wenn ich das umsetzen kann es gut
wenn nicht dann ist kacke ich verstehe
nicht alter vorhin ich habe genauso laut
geredet um eine spur war perfekt ich
pack das jetzt mal hier so optisch
satiren besser ist weil sie nicht
fragwürdig ich habe mein plan war ich
hole mir wow das sieht komisch aus
ich hole mir spruch verstärkung
laufenden ganz weiten weg so richtung
dahin wo man halt hin muss und springen
dann hoch zwar jetzt euro wo man hin
muss
helga ist dass diese komische ablage da
sind ich habe den blauen knopf schon
gefunden
ja aber ich ich ich denke die ablage
leute schaffe ich jetzt wohl darüber
siehst du die wirklich ich sehe es
wirklich so weit über dieser ablage
dieses goldene ist nicht die ablage ist
ok wo muss ich jetzt denn rein springen
weil hier ist nichts wo wasser ist von
ganz hoch auf die erde springen hätte
einmal am riemen wasser leute ich weiß
auch nicht ob ich das überlebe oder gibt
es irgendeinen anderen weg darauf zu
kommen es gibt keinen näheren weg als
den den ich hab doch dauert es noch nass
da muss ich hin
so leute ab zu dem es zudem aus geht's
ab ovo ist dass man locker wie findest
du das denn lukat modus des herodes auf
jeden ich bin und ich bin tot schnell
und ausruhen auf dem weg zu der kiste zu
der kiste zu der gäste zu der kiste
eventuelle zweiten cassidy finde aber
meinem dritten diamanten
wie kann es sein und ich habe ja wo bist
du crafter holt auf wo bist du mann
konkreter überholte spannung ist ein
riesiger gedeckter tisch alter siehst du
das nicht wo bist du denn ich bin bei so
einem großen vogel will ich mal und dann
kannst du sehen müssen wahrscheinlich
auch der komplett anderen seite durch
das level ist beendet für mich ich geh
weg zurück wieder eine lobby
du bist ein spaß ich finde ich stark
gemacht für mich auch heute geht man
alle daumen hoch wenn ihr denkt dass das
coni hier das gewinnt finja man das ist
so ähnlich wie bei epic jump das mit
links mit dem gas drehen dass es hier
auch seinem wettkampf ist ihr werdet ihr
auch vergaß er wohl ist in dieser blauen
knopf ich werde polizist neue level
anfang culex us- dollar und ich glaube
hinter dir her
nein nach hinten was du erster dem kopf
da beide zurück in die lobby
nein wirklich wirklich natürlich immer
drücken müssen wir voll im training von
earl trainiert soll ja schon das jetzt
echt machen müssen dass genialer plan
das ist gut dass du weißt wo die es
nicht einfach am kreis ja ich habe
irgendwo gesagt beim kreis ist es und
sonst nichts anderes
okay bei dir ich hab's gefunden
lenovo ist oder warum ich bin nicht ich
bin aber der ersten liga wir kommen
lieber 6 ohm rath wartet versteht weil
er sechs embryo max deine mutter meine
mutter ein embryo ja klar immer noch
what the [ __ ] bachmann ist so betrunken
in diesem hat diese motion wie das
aussah so richtig abartig ich will noch
kurz und vor allem mit dem chinesischen
essen wir brodelt alles im wasserbecken
das wasserbecken fackeln ein direkter
nehmen mussten den kopf rein springen
gegner suchen ja dann müsst ihr halte
den kopf gewachsen sagt dann versuchen
den kopf
ein wasserbecken ja ist in der hand was
macht so gott verdammt schwierig mit
dieser scheiß porsche
er hatte übelkeit ist das klug
kombiniert man junge alter ich wäre fast
ich wäre fast auch so spinnennetze
gefallen
aber du musst wirklich in diesen links
rein dabei die sachen das wasserbecken
nur scheiße alter das ist so gott
verdammt schwer mit dieser also brauchst
du echt brauchst echt glück dass da
irgendwas geht ich hab's geschafft
die gucke ich dachte auch springen das
wasser da ich bin aber ich bin jetzt
geklappt dass das direkt neben dem
wasser meinung halte das wirklich schon
denn die alten möbel echt schlecht gibt
die geht ihr weg die igel tja ich warte
einfach ein bisschen ich heiße alte
entweder auch voll schlecht oder sich
nicht geil
leute macht vollbild also wir gehen das
ja gerade recht durch steuern also da
unten unter die jetzt auf jeden fall der
schwarze schalter
das hab ich gesehen und klima
läuft leuten allein die taktik ich bin
gestorben
mit einer seite ehrlich ja jetzt mal vor
den schwarzen schalter gedrückt haben
ich habe mir ist diese übelkeit nicht
mehr da war kalter einen blog gar nicht
mehr also gerade eben ist nicht gekommen
aber jetzt ist wieder da werde ich habe
ein gutes gefühl
nein nicht so gut so soll ein dessen
schon halben im spinnennetz treffen
jetzt wieder im wasserbecken lucke junge
ich hoffe dass jetzt auch ich mache
jetzt einfach die augen zu während er
seinen alkohol abbauen ohne scheiß
wieder super eagles heftig man vor allem
leute fress mal vorher bitte drei
portionen chinesischen reis mit richtig
viel soße und spielt dann so ein spiel
hat die falschen treffen kletterte nicht
so toll ich bin schon ganz unten bei den
schwarzen ding beim schwarzen pläne was
ging schweizer kinder ihre penisse
einfach so weg
was du jetzt hier hin die hat dieses
behinderung von dem typen
ich würde ich springen jetzt einfach in
den kopf rein nein das kommt schon kommt
vom schon carlo eine scheiße
nein das darf nicht sein fick dich alte
ich bin gerade eben gesprungen habe aus
für sie noch mal ausdrücklich wer schon
da gewesen aber da komme ich wo ich
wieder rauskommen dann bist du die ganze
zeit hoch gesprungen das war schon
passiert aber ich bin jetzt wieder beim
schwarzen dinge
ich würde was ich meine wasser jammern
so leute als erstes team zu gott
verdammt weh es tut so weh zwei sekunden
noch eine sekunde ja geil bei server der
kiste ist alter als ob ich bin war der
kiste ich gerade so eine leiter runter
und der nächste diamant ist mehr junge
herbst geschafft
ich schwöre ich hab's geschafft ich fang
alter ich habs grad geschafft ich diese
scheiß rückhalt durch ich bin durch die
durch den kopf vom embryo jungen wir
schon 111 tore
bei uns läuft definitiv scheiße alter
mann ich habe es gerade geschafft als er
das doch ärgerlich so was er und bringt
dir was luca bringt dir was level 7
das bringt es mir wenn ich schaue
ausgegangen war
es heißt range eisel es bestimmt noch
mal doppelt so stelle der muss das alles
erst übelkeit level 6 ich fange schon
kam jedoch nicht alte aber sieht mégane
eyes aus ist mega ois ausgingen sieht
richtig geil aus da sind so die das
zellgewebe hat ich habe
[ __ ] fakt ist dass die finde ich im
geiste man einfach durchfahren mussten
nicht so denken weil denken
habt ihr gehört denkt ist sich max
stärke der stör hey du bist selbst
formel gestorben alter schnauze gutes
gefühl auf hat kam es immer sagen nicht
gutes gefühl
the feeling und dann läuft das hier bei
uns ich bin unten alter wie sie bisher
noch nicht gestorben
das wasser schießt unsichtbare junge
scheiße ich das mal gewusst
ich dachte ich hätte etwas muss ein
bisschen weg gelenkt junger machst du
tag alter habe ich nicht habe ich nicht
das tag all das ist überhaupt nicht weil
tag ist richtig scheiße das zu machen
auf jeden fall nicht weil du es ja ärger
dich hier ich kann unten entscheiden ob
tag oder nacht der junge mann nachts
alter ist doch scheiße sind
du hast nicht geschafft ich war es wie
immer wenn ich auf diesen knopf drücke
führung verstärkung dann wird es direkt
tag also willst direkt hält
ich werde es hilft einfach gar nichts
wenn du weißt dass hier ist es einfach
helfen
und nein es ist immer so knapp ist
einfach du denkst du bist schon unten
und dann ist alles und schweiß eisblock
lasst einfach raus lücke das einfach
raus hält jung ich wurde auch
teleportiert normalerweise wäre schon
längst unten mit qualität ist der
weltweit besten yamaha wird es mit dem
portier zu mir komm ich mag halt dein
maul nicht verrät sofort
ich mache keinen tag sondern alte der
veranstaltung brain brain brain
was ja der vor den fetten ist für dich
was denn du bist auch als sidebar oder
erst gut oder kafka gibt es sogar das
benutzen der spaß dies nutze ich habe
das damals richtig oft genutzte über ein
call of duty gesuchten zeiten wenn er
seine herumsteht und du du redest du
bist und skype mit einem und redest du
die ganze zeit bis zu seiner viera lobby
oder sogar brauchen teamspeak resultat
pay oder mit simon ist es mir echt so
simon reagiert dann einfach nicht wisse
ja des cabrio f12 erleuchten das allzeit
pray love hat das genauso wie ja du bist
über einkaufen oder so seine worte
leo lukas kummer wir sind jetzt nicht
nur bei denen gleich auch bei im
genannten ich hab's gehofft
das ist max geschlagen ist es
gegenwärtig herunter nein tut es nicht
es nicht guckt er wird nämlich hell wenn
man hier drauf drückt er ist ja egal
weil er geschafft aber womit hin
ich habe keine ahnung wirklich nicht
hier muss irgendwo ne kiste sein
irgendwo in diesem weiten
40 wir müssen irgendwie drauf springen
dann darüber laufen halte ist halt so so
ich bin auch nicht nein ich war drauf
warum springe ich dann noch mal was
nicht ist das fertig ist adam und eva
deine worte kamen so witzig bei dem
alter ist ein racer und schaltung die
heute schon mal auf den adlern drauf aus
denen reihe gewebe ach ich habe auf den
falschen knopf gedrückt ich bin raus
musste nicht nochmal machen
ich schwöre dir wir haben es dann schon
fast durch
nein es geht noch eine rückseite echt
insgesamt glaube ich 16
wir werden euch jetzt schon mal warum
werde ich denn hoch teleport hier zu
holen so war bei mir auch schon so jetzt
kommt wieder runter glaube ich bin ich
noch malta muss noch zum feiern habe ich
heiße ich war schon bei dings auf den
adern drauf so dass das ärgerliche ich
muss das jetzt auch noch mal schaffen
komplett ist ein quartier mir geklickt
als die kiste schon gefunden
jetzt hast ich schaffe es nicht mehr ich
sterbe aber ich weiß wo sie ist ich weiß
genau wer will ja ja ich seh sie ja ich
bin auch mit
naja werd ich nicht so als ob bisschen
spaß aber ich hab dich runter fallen
sehen wohin springt also da muss
irgendwo sein
ich habe mir probiert runterzufallen
oder doch nicht
es gehört wie ich die kiste gerade nicht
das gute alte einfache hier müsste
irgendwo die kiste sein das kann nicht
weiß wo die kiste ist älter ich suchte
hier die ganze zeit
ich habe glück ich hatte ja ich war
schon die das ist viel länger hast du da
unten
habt ihr auch die ganze zeit besucht als
er wenig einmal unten hin und wieder zum
schwarzen knopf kommen da habe ich
gewonnen alter dann habe ich die da hab
ich dir immerhin sicher was da wenn ich
jetzt finde dann fick dich bewegst dich
und ich schalte ich gucke jetzt einfach
wo du hin springst
hey sind überall sowie egal da muss
jedoch auch irgendwo die kiste sein
ich weiß genau gefällt einfach ein tipp
man einen tipp gegeben wo die kiste war
beiden letzten ich habe auch einen
diamanten ich habe ihr und diamanten
diamanten gegeben hast du gar nicht
mitbekommen oder alter wir müssen schon
längst ein cut machen so läuft wir
machen jetzt neben cannes mit zwanzig
minuten fast total vergessen mein kopf
dran
nächster test morgen bei kran crafter
der hier immer noch verzweifelt versucht
vor ganz oben runter zu springen und
dann würde ich sagen es euch gefallen
hat würden wir uns definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen
das zeigt uns dass euch gefallen hat und
was wir verbessern können so nach dem
motto und ja da macht's gut
wir lieben euch gebt euch noch mehr
ich liebe euch immer zwei mal mehr als
der vögel welche spiegel spiegel spiegel
das heißt ich liebe euch vier mal